Hello and welcome to fire of learning
the Myers Briggs type indicator as an
increasingly popular subject
as a personality test,
which assigns you four letters,
which determine certain preferences
for decision making and highly your
perspectives on things
and things like that.
I've made several videos
on the subject already,
but we can't really talk about NBTI
without discussing the scientific validity
of it. Some people claim as a fairly
useful reference for personalities.
Others are concerned
that it's pseudoscience,
perhaps just astrology with
a psychological theme or
perhaps even that maybe
it's not pseudoscience,
but the results aren't all that useful.
So what's going on here?
Well,
let's start it by saying that many aspects
of psychology to begin with are a bit
of a jungle to navigate there,
especially personality psychology,
which is why at times it's harder to
determine the objective and the scientific
validity of a psychological claim.
And it would be to address the comparable
scientific question of physics or
biology or something like that.
As research is a time subject to more
variables in errors in psychology.
Regardless,
under no circumstances should we abandon
the scientific method and thought
process and we shall not do.
So here there's a million personality
tests and each of them must be weighed by
its predictability, consistency,
and applicability. And
as far as the NBTI goes,
the evidence when it is examined beyond
a superficial understanding seems to
suggest validity and accuracy.
So we're going through explain why and
then we're going to address counter
arguments.
So the Myers Briggs type indicator assigns
you after taking a test for letters
based off of four little dichotomy
leading to 16 different types.
The letters indicate whether you are an
I or an e and introvert or an extrovert,
an s or an end,
a sensor or an intuitor,
a t or an f as thinker or a feeler and
a j or a p, a judger or a perceiver.
If you're not fully aware of what
these terms mean, don't worry.
We'll address each dichotomy
here and each type, as I said,
supposedly gives it an
analysis of your personality,
but highlighting her decision
making preferences and perspectives.
Let's get into the letters I versus e,
introversion versus extroversion.
That's kind of already a commonly
understood concept and one which I have
personally never really encountered
serious criticism of on its own and so
beyond saying that obviously it like every
other little review here is more of a
preference on a spectrum
and a different difference.
I he most people are not good Gary as
entertainers or hermetic introverts most
lie in between extremes.
I won't really spend much time addressing
this concept accordingly as versus an
sensing versus intuition. What's
this will according to what is said,
intuitive types and types handle
abstract concepts and ideas pretty well.
Generally they look for expanding meeting
and things that contemplate the big
picture very well, et cetera. Whereas
ss I'm more pragmatic down to earth.
They referred immediate facts and
details and enjoy accompanying systems.
They're not really all that interested
in abstract things. Now tests clarify.
Obviously everyone spends time doing
practical pragmatic thinking and everyone
spends time with abstract concepts. It's
more of a spectrum. As I said. However,
the difference is not inconsequential
and there was a reason the three fourths
of people are s's and one fourth
test and in the United States,
while sensor types are necessarily stupid,
I know a few acids with in fact,
high Iq is the traits of intuitive types
seem to correlate to higher abilities
to contemplate abstract concepts which
is closely linked to above average Iq.
Thankfully,
this isn't just my speculation.
There's been tests on this exact question.
Here's some charts showing the results
of those tests and of course lengths of
the research and a description.
What we see here is interesting.
Firstly see the correlation
between introversion and Iq,
which is also an already established
and scientifically backed correlation,
but I won't expand on that in this video.
What is important though is that
intuitive types line up perfectly with the
higher Iq scores as opposed to ss with
a little bit of currently negligible
differences between t's and F's and peas
and Jay's with the INTP according to
this research coming out on top.
Now this doesn't mean that all ends have
gifted Iq or that all acids, as I said,
do not.
And we could of course spend all day
pondering the meaning of different values
for different kinds of intelligence
and intelligence is and all that.
But when it comes to Iq and subsequently
the closely linked concept of abstract
intelligence,
the gifted have greater likelihoods of
testing and then s reinforcing what is in
my opinion and obvious correlation.
Furthermore,
I think this dispels a ridiculous notion
that Acu has no meaningful effect on
someone's personality.
And to expand on that,
if we look at the personality
traits of a High Iq person such as,
for example, a quick comprehension of
abstract topics, creativity, curiosity,
fear of failure, rejection of authority
in favor of independent conclusions.
We see basically the same traits which
the NBTI describes as intuitive types.
Let's move on to thinking
versus feeling t versus uh,
according to the NBTI information,
simply put,
t's prefer to make decisions based off
of objective criteria and the quarterly
favor decisions and solutions to problems
which are in accordance with facts and
data.
Efs prefer to make decisions based on
a set of values and favor decisions and
solutions which are in
accordance with those values.
And what the greater human factor
in mind for whatever reason.
Some people to spell this as being
completely unfactual and not based on
anything but really when you examine
the evidence to find that thinking is
preferred by about 56% of males,
but more importantly feeling is preferred
by 75% of females and then we compare
what is found through to psychology
studies and demonstrate that men have a
tendency to make decisions based on
objective criteria and offer solutions to
problems.
Whereas women are more empathetic and
more often offer support for problems.
It's fairly obvious that was a TF
dichotomy is highlighting are these
scientifically backed differences?
I've seen plenty of criticism towards
NBTI stating that emotions and empathy for
other people are independent of
processes involved with logical thought,
but that's not what Nbti highlights.
It highlights more of a
decision making process,
not how well people understand logic or
how empathetic people aren't necessarily
now for the difference in perception
versus judging according to the Myers
Briggs descriptions. Perceivers
ps essentially prefer flexibility.
They prefer to improvise
their plans and be adaptable.
There are a little bit more spontaneous
and they prefer to work in bursts of
enthusiasm rather than
in an organized plan.
Judgers Jay's prefer to have a structure
to this schedule one daily life and
pursuits and such as ever
perhaps a bit more organized.
They prefer to stick to
plans and things like that.
To put it more in terms of what Carl Young
stated when he identified a cognitive
functions, perceivers prefer to judge
things internally and perceive externally.
Whereas judges per sort of prefer to
perceive things internally and an exercise
or judgments on the external world.
There are a number of ways to address
this beyond just citing studies that prove
the obvious. It's some people prefer
flexibility and others the organization,
one such study is average
income according to type.
Now what you would expect from a judger
that has a say to someone who has a
preference for extroverted thinking or
feeling one with first to act on their
environment a bit more will display
a dry to achieve higher economic or
otherwise success and what easily end
up in positions of leadership which tend
to pay higher and such.
Statistics show exactly this.
The ENT J by far has the
highest average income,
probably a mixture of extroverted thinking
and intuition followed by the EST j
the Eso j and then the Nfj Ist Jay and
I and t j sort of have about the same
level of average income according to
this chart and only after that that we
start to see perceiving
types of GSTP and enf p.
Some surveys differ a little bit,
but consistently extroverted thinkers
and feelers, Aka judging types.
Jay's except of course for ISF J's and
nine of Jay's who are a bit different,
tend to have higher average incomes
than other proceeding types.
Reinforcing the notion
that this is not arbitrary,
so that's basically the argument
concerning the scientific backing of NBTI.
Evidence seems to suggest that these
personality differences and descriptions
have a correlation to scientifically
back to research if it's not a survey or
study of the types of cells.
Descriptions can often be supported by
other scientific studies which show a
connection and it's correlation can
be shown to not just be happenstance.
The type predicts behavior and numerous
studies have shown an accuracy in
prediction. With all this in mind,
it's time to address some criticisms.
Having dedicated actual time to research,
to objectively and scientific question
and analyze the personality types.
I am a Middle East,
somewhat frustrated by people who've
denounced it without properly analyzing it
because it comes such conclusions
about things without contemplation and
research is overall harmful,
especially when your opinion is taken
into serious consideration by the public.
Some have made videos or written
articles announcing NBTI for misguided or
incorrect reasons along
the lines of we'll man,
you can't define people with do
four letters, dude role unique,
but I suppose taking such a starkly
abrasive stance with a little more than
superficial understanding
and bad reasoning is why you
could come to expect from
many modern media sites these days.
And I accordingly take pride in ensuring
that extra steps are taken to make sure
that fire of learning is not on that
boat and is as intellectually honest as
possible to the point at which if the
entirety of my stance here were to be
proven wrong,
I would delete this video and all Myers
Briggs videos to replace them with a
video explaining why I was wrong.
But anyway,
back to the point Allison Fox and
the post writes an article about the
superficial reality of Myers Briggs
types placing at the beginning of her
article, this is where we call bs
personality tests me, nothing, nothing.
This is to begin with a red flag because
it's fairly obviously false claim to
make.
Well,
it may be in fact true that scientifically
human behavior can be as reliably
predicted as physical behavior of
asteroids to suggest that it's so
unpredictable and random that I can be
organized in the general types of general
descriptions,
general descriptions,
mind you not 100% accurate and predictable
categories is an unjustifiable claim.
We are each of us perhaps different on
the individual level and even on that
individual level decisions we make and
our behaviors can very unpredictably,
but it's totally misguided to believe
that similarity and personalities and not
exist at those personality similarities
can not be identified and labeled into
specific types and that a personality quiz
can not identify these similar traits.
This is why psychologists use tests.
They have a bit more preference for the
big five personality tests and NBTI,
which we'll explain in a moment,
but I'm sorry if it hurts your feelings,
but everyone can be identified and grouped
according to share personality traits
and they are quite frankly consequential.
The author here's fairly vague and doesn't
specify what she means by personality
test because quite frankly,
something like an anxiety or depression
test can be equated to a personality
test and no one would claim
that these are inconsequential.
In the same way that the
author who believes Mpti is
because such aspects of the
human mind play a major role in how people
function and it is obviously accepted
as such, traits lead to similar behaviors
in people which can be identified.
Adam Grant also from the
Huffington post shares her opinion.
He begins by stating that
originally when taking a test,
he typed IMTJ a few months later
he came back and type II SFP.
If you see my videos, you know that
these are inverted forums of each other.
The I and T J is n. I. T. E.
F. I. N. S. E. The ESF is s.
E. F. I. T. E. N. N. I. He evidently
claims at the types are so superficial,
but even the distinction between
complete opposite types is arbitrary and
unfounded,
which is entirely misguided and
observing an average IMTJ and ESF p.
The difference is immediately evidence.
I've never met any ESF Jay's who were
actually more like me than what their type
descriptions mentioned,
but of course my personal experience is
not what is used in scientific analysis
necessarily.
Ergo,
I would have to ask this author to
explain the consistent statistical link
between Income Iq,
profession, gender, etc,
and Nbti if these types
are so superficial.
He mentioned 16 personalities.com that's
a fairly common sight to take the NBTI.
That's where I first took it. Might
type by the way, has never changed.
I've taken multiple different tests and
each of them I've scored INTP except for
on one,
which I was typed IMTJ no.
All my personality results on this
particular test could be brushed off as
obviously I took just
one bad test for others.
The author makes a
shocking statement would,
which is often brought up an NBTI
discussion that a considerable amount of
people,
perhaps even three quarters of people
come back to take the test and test as a
different type.
I have no doubts that people do miss type.
I myself have seen people get the wrong
type and fine traits within that wrong
type,
which are applicable to them,
but usually the mistype is not extremely
far off and the fact that at times
people do miss type does not
invalidated types themselves.
Ms [inaudible] occurs in all
similar personality quizzes,
not necessarily because
the test lack any depth,
but because often people change their
answers in accordance with what they'd
like to be treated rather than
what is true. Take. For example,
my ms types quiz result. Perhaps on that
quiz I'm misunderstood some questions.
Perhaps a test wasn't specific enough.
I could have even overestimated or change.
My answer is there's
something of that nature.
Imagine if that had been my initial
assault upon learning about NBTI and I
subsequently believe that I
wasn't Imtj and read description.
The description may have indeed been
applicable to me in many aspects.
I may have read it and found
that relatively fitting
even though there were some
things which weren't necessarily true.
Now this is also where a considerable
amount of criticism towards the NBTI comes
in.
People seem to think like astrology.
Each type simply offering the list of
traits which are ambiguous and good.
Their board therefore be applied to
everyone and so people are tricked into
finding it meaningful.
By that logic,
though I could have even typed
ESF and founded applicable.
Anyone familiar with a Myers Briggs types,
however knows this is not remotely true
and often many people retake the test
and get a different result because
they're original result isn't applicable.
If I had been identified as an I and Tj,
it wouldn't have been long until I or
my friends who introduced the subjects.
I mean noticed it was an
error based on the behavior,
especially when I was
introduced to the of functions.
It's blatantly clear that
the types referred to very
specific personality traits
in such arguments, I believe do not
invalidate the types themselves.
It probably hint more towards a notion
now the common tests allow room for error
and bias,
which should be closed and more questions
should be specified to produce more
accurate results.
Although admittedly it is true that
many online tests are more interested in
reminded and helping people accurately
identified a type accordingly,
I would venture to guess that these myths
types are generally off by one or two
litters and happen because it tests
is taken without much introspection or
seriousness.
Maybe an NFP is actually an eye NFP.
Maybe an EST j is actually an ESF Jay,
maybe an INTP is actually an eye FGA.
I have never once,
and this is just my personal experience
to take with a grain of salt,
but in the year that I've
been studying this stuff,
I have never once encountered an
individual who mistyped as the complete
opposite type and I have no idea how our
author here managed to go from Imtj to
ESF Pete.
That would require basically answering
completely opposites on each question and
I accordingly have to wonder what test
was this exactly how much thought was put
into the answering of each question.
Do people really so easily go from being
introverted, preferring abstract topics,
making decisions based on objective
criteria and preferring structure and
organization to daily life,
to jumping to extroversion,
preferring practical cons that I was
making decisions empathetically and with
values and preferring flexibility and
openness so easily that NBTI is useless or
maybe were some answers intentionally
altered an aura to write this article.
Who can say for sure,
but quite frankly the bottom line is that
if these results were so arbitrary of
people could not identify meaningful
correlations or statistics which have been
proven to exist. Iq
results, income averages,
result averages compared with the janitor
would not line up consistently and we
would likely have each type evenly
distributed into sixteenths among the
population.
None of this is the case in each of these
authors have little ground on which to
make their assertions.
He then goes on to write the rest of
the article backing it up with other
misconceptions which I believe I have
addressed here such as implying that
thinking and feeling are independent
of each other, which sure that is true,
but how about in decision making
process thinkers can like people,
feelers can be logical.
It's about how people make
decisions in the interest of time.
If something does stick out,
which I haven't covered,
alert me in the comments section,
I'll address it there.
Further criticism run along the same
lines. Looking at this video from vox,
which isn't itself a red flags.
Anyone looking for an objective and valid
analysis of the topic because vox has
a fairly decent record of making
inaccurate in shallow videos.
They percent largely the same
incorrect arguments they claim.
Of course everyone is too special and
unique to share any identifiable traits
and they quote Carl youngest saying every
individual is an exception to the rule
as if this was opposed to cover literally
every aspect of the human experience
and infer only 16 such
experience that exists.
They claim it's all a big scam to
make money off gullible people will.
I'm not making a penny off this just
for the record and the most common tests
are in themselves free.
They mentioned that employers use a test
to assign people into jobs and imply
that this is an awful idea.
Then according to their animation
and for that the Ist Jay is a mentor.
The INTP as a manager and
the ESF Jay is an analyst.
You may take that as you will and
other points they make is that the test
results only give you
positive descriptions. That
really isn't entirely false.
The websites themselves do sort of
butter people up to encourage them to get
into it more.
But I have an a four videos I've made
addressing the 16 types criticized each
and every type. There are traits I dislike
about every type, including my own.
Just because of marketers don't
highlight negative aspects.
It doesn't mean they don't exist.
They even throw in those viral images
of the suppose the types of fictional
characters.
If the characters are developed enough,
fictional characters can be typed,
although it's kind of awkward to do.
And I would like to concede that the
online community more interested in
applying NBTI as a fad,
more like astrology than to use it
as an actual tool for understanding
personalities do tend to degrade
the image of the subject.
Pause where you need to. But take for
example, this should be more like this.
This should be more like this and this.
It should be more like this.
This should be more like this,
and this just doesn't make any sense.
So to summarize a bit here,
the validity of the Myers Briggs
types lies beyond confirmation bias.
As we can see a correlation, scientific
data, what the letters represent,
line up a psychological data which is
either conducted specifically with Nbti
mine or parallels with sciences,
otherwise shown criticisms of Myers
Briggs types tend to not criticize these
points.
They generally just look at superficial
understanding and accordingly make
misguided arguments. So I feel comfortable
in this analysis and critique. However,
I have not addressed
one final major quaint.
The fact of the matter is
most psychologists aren't
big fans of it. Well why?
I mean it's been shown the
have scientific backing, yes.
But psychologists have admittedly
invented better systems to categorize
personality is a big one now that that
like is the big five and I could spend
another 10 minutes showing
how NBTI correlates to the
big five and various ways,
but I think that the big five in general
and other parts of psychology are a
topic for another video.
Really though Myers Briggs types,
while they can be very useful
and revealing and build
bridges of understanding
between people are affective mostly.
As a general reference telling you that
I am an INTP will give you insight into
my personality, but it's certainly
does not tell you everything.
Knowing that someone is an I in of j or
an ESP doesn't really provide insight
into their home life,
their mental health or overall health
or their life experiences, their values,
tradition or culture,
et Cetera, et cetera.
And from a perspective of a psychologist,
it's easy to see why it
doesn't tell them enough,
particularly if they're
conducting research or
assisting a client in a form of
therapy or something,
they will likely have to rely on other
systems or look at people on a more
specific and individual level.
So that's about all I have to say
about Myers Briggs types. For now,
I wholeheartedly welcome criticism
in the comment section and encourage
respectful debate between viewers.
If you're looking to learn more about
NBTI have made for analysis videos in
youtube videos explaining the letters
and cognitive functions on my channel,
which I encourage you to check out and
for more videos on subjects like this and
many other subjects in the future
and which I've already made,
be sure to check off fire learning
and subscribe. Thank you for watching.